does it bother you that it's raining no
in fact it's this rain that creates all
of the beautiful Tuscan agriculture all
of the olives in the wine that we
consume is a product of this rain and
understand too when you're breathing
this air it's this air that creates all
the amazing Italian cuisine that you're
gonna enjoy tonight for dinner the air
the water the Sun just understand that
Italians in particular have a connection
with the earth litera and in fact it is
the conditions and of the environment
that is a paramount importance to the
Italian Italian wine is not labeled by
grape no one cares what the grape is
people care where is it from one of the
great things about Florence is that
everything's kind of very condensed so
you can see all these beautiful
locations one right after another so
this is Santa Croce this is the Piazza
de Santa Croce and now it's just a short
walk to the Piazza della Signoria and
now during the day sometimes it adds a
tendency to become crowded with tourists
but I prefer solitude and I'll go there
late at night and just kind of be alone
with all the history there it allows me
the chance to really connect with
everything that's come before as opposed
to the here and now there's a rich
history of Florence a history of art the
history of romance and sometimes when
you're alone and you really have time to
think about all the things that have
occurred here it really hits you it
really gives you that sense of
fulfillment they see these shops are
great sabaki
tobacco and they sell cigarettes but
they sell all kinds of odds and ends
kind of like the Italian version of a
small 7-eleven you see if you're a
painter you could turn any corner perch
and easel and paint from that vantage
point now you know pigeons are often
associated with Venice but in fact
you'll find pigeons all over all the
Italian cities incredibly strong birds
certainly Rome has quarters where you
would walk around
however Florence the entire city is
accessible on foot it's intimate it
makes you feel like you can wrap your
mind around you you don't get lost in it
you are a part of the city a sea there
are a lot of cities in the world where
if you want to be exposed to art you
have to go to a museum pay admission fee
and look at a painting in Florence we
are in the painting and in fact I really
go to museums while I'm in town here we
are immersed in beauty we are immersed
in art and we are immersed in history
look at this painting step outside
yourself and look at the two of us
walking down the street in Florence and
admire the beauty of the situation right
now this is why I come alone I consider
these things as I walk these streets I'm
in a painting the thoughts in my head
are very dynamic and some would think
chaotic but in fact I can make order of
it all and guess these are things that
occur to me and that's the inner
exploration that I'm talking about is
understanding your place in history your
connection to the world around you we're
not observers we are participants you
know in Europe you'll find that exercise
as part of people's everyday lives you
don't need to go to a gym to lift
weights to get your daily dose of
exercise your daily dose of exercise
comes from walking from point A to point
B ascending a staircase taking an
after-dinner walk like a sledge octa the
point is that exercise is the point as a
part of everyday life in Italy and most
of Europe you see I feel invigorated
walking is something that we miss in Los
Angeles we should appreciate this
situation we find ourselves in truffles
are very rare because they only grow
wild they cannot be cultivated
furthermore there are three primary
types of truffles there are the white
truffles which only grow in winter there
are the black truffles which grow in
winter and there are the black summer
truffles as far as I'm concerned
concerned the only one worth buying
would be the white truffle unfortunately
it is the most expensive a white truffle
of that size may cost 500 euro now the
dogs that find truffles are also very
expensive because if you have a good dog
an owner can make thousands and
thousands of dollars in a truffle season
so you look at every one of these wine
shops sell local wines only so for
example you're not gonna find a napa
cabernet here and you're not gonna find
any kind of French Bordeaux or burgundy
here these are Cortona you're not even
gonna find a wine from Piemonte day here
or Chianti is hard to find here because
that's already an hour away it's all
about local stuff here too often in life
we only enjoy something when it's a
memory now there are a lot of reasons
for that maybe in that moment you're
distracted maybe you're restrained too
with some social activity look at this
tobacco shop I buy things and I ship
them large boxes things I collect
throughout my trips Italy I bring them
there
I ship them whatever it may be I should
olive oil from there I should have to
wind from there a Leo is garlic so you
don't need to ship that the great garlic
actually coming from Gilroy California
it's the garlic capital of the world at
least that's what they like to say now
that's Northern California in fact
there's so much garlic there when you
drive through there even on the freeway
you can smell garlic in the air of
course there are garlic souvenir shops
you could buy garlic keepers you can buy
garlic killers I don't use a garlic
peeler why it's another piece of a
kitchen equipment that really gets used
if I'm gonna have a piece of equipment
in my kitchen I like it to be able to be
multi test so I'll take one thing that
can be used for many things for example
I have a potato masher okay I'll mash
potatoes with it I may also use it to
tenderize a steak or flatten a steak one
tool use it for two purposes no matter
how much I enjoy your company to some
extent you are a distraction from my
enjoyment of the landscape because I'm
participating in a conversation with you
it requires thought it requires
consideration when I'm alone I can be
free to enjoy the lands around me
without having to worry about am I
saying something that's adequately
responding to a question that you have
understand these are small distractions
I like to clear my mind normally there
are virtues to both methods these are
san marzano tomatoes and salt there's no
sauce there's no oregano
there's no garlic there's none of that
there are four ingredients in front of
you there is red tomatoes mozzarella
cheese specifically for zealot a which
signifies a mozzarella cheese from cows
not from Buffalo even though this region
Campania is famous for its buffalo
mozzarella
the buffalo mozzarella is too wet to
make a good pizza and finally there's
basil and that's it
different people cut at different ways
you can cut it however you want you can
cut it into squares
there's triangles whatever it is I cut
it the traditional way one down the
middle rotate it one down the middle
again and basically cut it into what
amounts to eight slices
it's the classic way and Who am I to
mess with a good tradition it's not
difficult to eat a sandwich yet you seem
to struggle with it
you put the sandwich up to your mouth
you bite and everything that you bite
off goes in your mouth if it's hanging
out of your mouth you've bitten too much
buy less next time and if your first
bite shows you that I can't judge the
sandwich adequately I'm biting too much
then the next time you say I'll bite a
little bit less maybe that'll be the
perfect amount nothing will be hanging
out of my mouth dripping into my wine
the meat of this region in particular is
the tally otta names tally arias t'cut
Battaglia is caught it's a sliced steak
and the Cortona is a version has green
peppercorns and rosemary it's a very
local preparation and I know what you
like and I feel like you will like this
and then for the pasta they have a pasta
called Arquette's al fumo which has
bacon in it which I know you like you're
big on bacon it's got bacon it's in
looks like creamy tomato sauce and I
feel like that would be good for you as
well so that's the case we'll get that
will do a complete Italian meal
antipasto primo Segundo Dolce after the
Dolce we take a cafe after the cafe we
take a DJs Stevo also called the Amata
cafe
they after-dinner drink a matzah Cafe is
the coffee killer why coffee keeps you
up late at night the a matzo cafe that
after dinner drink puts you to sleep
after the coffee well I think I'm going
to sleep just fine
you